-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Former President Trump
held a rally
on Saturday in Waco, Texas,
near the site of
the Branch Davidian cult's
compound,
or as it's now known,
campaign headquarters.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
held a campaign rally
on Saturday in Waco, Texas,
making him the first cult leader
ever to escape that city alive.
[ Laughter ]
During his rally on Saturday,
former President Trump
mocked Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis
and said he has,
"no personality,"
which based on the past,
makes him frontrunner for VP.
[ Laughter ]
During his rally on Saturday
in Texas,
former President Trump
dismissed claims
that he had an affair with
adult-film star Stormy Daniels
and mocked her appearance.
You're mocking her appearance?
Remember that picture
of the two of you together?
This looks like a picture
you'd see on Facebook
with the caption,
"Last time seeing Grandpa."
[ Laughter ]
Russian President --
Russian President Vladimir Putin
announced over the weekend
that Russia has reached
a deal with Belarus
to station nuclear weapons
in its territory.
The deal announcement
came as a surprise
both to NATO and Belarus.
[ Laughter ]
[ Eastern European accent ]
"Starting when?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Officials in
Philadelphia announced yesterday
that tap water
is safe to drink
after a toxic spill
in the Delaware River.
That's right, Philly residents
can drink water,
but they still
can't pronounce it.
W-Wooter.
Okay.
No, go with wooter.
Officials in California
recently responded
after a truck overturned
and spilled a load
of 10,000 empty wine bottles
onto the road.
They hadn't seen that many
empty wine bottles
since week two
of COVID lockdown.
[ Laughter ]
An 80-year-old woman in Canada
recently received
the Guinness World Record
for most blood donated.
Said the woman, "I'm 26."
[ Laughter ]
A high school principal
in Florida
recently resigned
after she received criticism for
showing students Michelangelo's
sculpture of David,
which one parent
allegedly called pornographic.
And I can't believe
I never noticed this before,
but they might have a point.
[ Laughter ]
You never notice that part
because...
you're looking
at the tiny wang.
[ Laughter ]
I took art history class.
That's how I know
what to call it.
The TSA announced last week
that it's now classifying
peanut butter as a liquid.
So bad news -- Now you're
going to have to chug that
at security, too.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
New York City today
launched its curbside
composting program,
or as rats are calling it,
Restaurant Week.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue.